looking for a good strong drink that
takes under a minute to concoct here are
the top seven easiest cocktails to whip
up for any occasion number seven in LA
stopping by stir things up with an alpha
male classic the gin martini at number
six get weird throw on some swim trunks
from the bottom of your dresser and
pretend you're in Miami then make a
mojito it should take the edge off of
the judgmental stares you'll be getting
from others when life doesn't give you
lemons but screw it you want them anyway
make it Tom Collins number five on our
best and easiest cocktail list number
four on the list well we've got out of
season fruit on the counter try the hard
Arnold Palmer also known as the Jon Daly
and number three is this inspired yet
simple Negroni
[Music]
Mexico's favorite hangover cure is
number two on our list the Mitchell
oughtta make it spicy or don't make it
at all
and finally still the easiest still the
most reliable and still the most
delicious cocktail you can make the gin
and tonic
it's not rocket science it's just really
damn good have a lazy friend who needs a
strong drink for the holidays be sure to
check out the full recipes on the GQ
channel and pass the buzz along
[Music]